6 23 it's Wednesday morning and all I
can tell you folks at home is it smells
like my Mom's Kitchen in here it is
National spaghetti day and joining us
now to celebrate Richard camarata from
Bala Italiana Seoul I believe to
pronounce that right the restaurant cool
well Italian Seoul so thanks for having
me over there's a hair right yeah it's
been a great start thank you welcome
Richard so y'all been open for about
four months how are the crowds they're
loving you doing very well very well we
are we do spaghetti we do all sorts of
types of fresh pasta we make everything
in-house we do amazing focaccias we do
some small pizzas but Bala Italian soul
is very much focused on kind of the
classic southern Mediterranean Cuisine
uh and yeah it's been a great start so I
cook it good no go ahead John I was
gonna say you know I'm very con I know
how to eat the pasta one of the
questions I've just had to make the
pasta on this National spaghetti what's
the secret to a perfectly cooked pasta
like this well so the key obviously make
sure you uh figure out how long you want
to cook your pasta right so this fresh
pasta is about three three and a half
minutes and then the other key have your
sauce kind of built out the biggest
thing don't throw away your pasta water
you gotta use your pasta water
I have to drain the pasta drain my
name you want to use a little of this
water this is what this is what creates
all that nice natural starch and watch
as I start to kind of put this together
we're going to bring this all together
and some of that starchy nice water will
help loosen it up and it just kind of
creates this all nice emulsification and
that's what gets you you know that
beautiful Sheen and everything goes on
with it
exactly oh I love that so what's the key
to making good pasta from scratch well
if you want to make good pasta at home
you're going to need a few pieces of
equipment you're going to need an
extruder things like that yeah it's not
necessarily the easiest thing to do yeah
so this is an extruded pasta we do it
just semolina and water that's all
that's in here wow so great beautiful
Italian stimulated flour but you can
also do rolled pastas which are egg egg
dough and then that's a little bit
different certainly a lot more
achievable at home I've been making some
with my son he's really excited about
making pasta so we use a KitchenAid and
you can roll it out it's been a lot of
fun you attach it to the top of like a
Cuisinart it stretches it out right yeah
my mom wants one of those real bad you
know okay so maybe you don't want to
make the pasta maybe that's a bit of a
challenge the sauce is of course vital
yeah you can and it depends on the kind
of sauce this is a Bolognese so it
depends on what the ingredients are it
depends on the sauce what's the key you
know start with great tomatoes whether
they're fresh if you can use fresh
tomatoes obviously this time of year
you're gonna have a hard time finding
great fresh tomatoes there's great Camp
products out there and then from there
you want to just develop flavors on top
Sherry's already ready
I'm like I love looking at it but I
really like eating all right so a nice
simple little twist
make it all pretty and you said you add
some stuff on top too I'm going to show
you guys okay all right because we do
want to taste it before we go John where
are the forks who eats pasta with a fork
just use your hands what's the big deal
right here I need the four where where's
this where's the silverware all right
well we're gonna do that right here we
got a four three out of four we got a
fork we're good we're honest with a
little bit of a dried oregano thank you
thank you a little bit of fennel seed I
love a little fresh basil I just like to
take mine and kind of rip it up a little
bit
so something for you to think about at
home while you're making your dinner
after you've been at work been at school
or whatever the case may be make
yourself a little pasta simple tools and
I'll tell you the pasta water really is
key that is something that I have
learned from my own mother and she tells
me that so yeah uh Richard thanks for
coming in from Italian Seoul over at the
Sahara thanks for coming in and
indulging Us in some pasta and I think
it's time to get some breakfast for
dinner yeah for dinner for breakfast
appreciate it oh my gosh Richard this is
so amazing
heavenly
[Music]